Hallo, guten Tag.
Guten Morgen, mein Name ist Ismail.
Ich bin heute Diensthabende für die Rüste 3.
Als wir uns über Ihre aktuellen Becherven unterhalten,
würde ich Ihnen gerne über Ihre Personiendaten
einige Fragen stellen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Manfred Loman.
Manfred Loman.
Könnt ihr bitte Ihren Ahname einmal bestellen?
Ja, Loman schreibt sich L-O-H-M-A-N-N.
Loman.
Double N.
Ja.
Herr Loman.
Frau Loman.
Nein, Herr Loman.
Herr Loman.
Sprich ich richtig aus?
Ja.
Okay, Herr Loman.
Wann sind Sie gerne aufgeboren?
Am 24. März 1962.
1962.
Wie alt sind Sie?
63 Jahre.
63 Jahre alt, ja.
Ja.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,80 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Zur Zeit 70 kg.
70 kg.
Okay, Herr Loman.
Was führt Sie zu uns?
Was für Beschwerden haben Sie?
Ja, also in den letzten Wochen habe ich mich insgesamt müde gefühlt.
Ich bin ziemlich schwach, ich muss viel schlafen.
Ich habe auch Husten und auch Luftnot.
Das hat sich in den letzten Wochen ziemlich verstärkt.
Und ich kann nicht mehr gut liegen.
Da bekomme ich keine Luft im Liegen.
Im Liegen.
Hab mich richtig verstanden.
Sie hatten seit einer Woche.
Seit einigen Wochen Müdigkeit und Abgeschreiheit.
Und Luftnot und Husten.
Ja.
Okay.
Seit wann haben Sie Husten?
Ganz genau, Husten und Luftnot.
Auch seit einigen Wochen, oder?
Mit Husten habe ich häufig zu tun gehabt,
weil ich bis vor einem Jahr stark geraucht habe.
Und da hatte ich dann schon häufig so Art Raucher-Husten.
Und chronische Bronchitis, wie man mir gesagt hat.
Okay.
Sie haben chronische Bronchitis?
Ja, ich glaube schon.
Ja.
Haben Sie bei Ihrer Beine geschwollt?
Also das habe ich nicht bemerkt,
dass meine Beine irgendwie stark geschwollt sind.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen,
dass die Luftnot in der Nacht
oder beim Liegen verschwollt ist?
Also ich kann nicht gut flach liegen.
Ich kann sowieso seit einigen Wochen nicht mehr.
Da brauche ich immer zwei Kissen.
Und in letzter Zeit kann ich auch nicht gut auf der rechten Seite liegen.
Dann ist die Luft noch schlechter,
wenn ich auf der rechten Seite liege.
Wenn ich auf der rechten Seite liege,
dann bekomme ich eine schlechte Luft.
Ja.
Haben Sie Ausluft?
Ja, der ist so gelbbräunlich.
Manchmal ist er auch so rötlich, hellrot.
Rötlich.
Gibt es Blut in Ihrer Ausluft?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das Blut ist.
Das sieht manchmal so ein bisschen hellrot aus.
Das sieht sich so wie im Schleim, wie in Fäden.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich habe nicht gemessen.
Ich habe aber nicht den Eindruck, dass ich Fieber habe.
Fühlen Sie sich febrig?
Nein.
Es gibt bei Ihnen Brustschmerzen,
oder Brustschmerzen?
Nein, Brustschmerzen habe ich nicht.
Das sieht wirklich so aus.
Ja, ja.
Die Brustschmerzen in der Ausluft sind so gelbbräunlich.
Nein.
Haben Sie beim Wusten Schmerzen?
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Luftnot ganz genau beschreiben, wenn Sie bewegen oder belasten, dann...
Also auch wenn ich mich bin, aber auch so müde.
Also wenn ich Treppen steigen muss, ich wohne in der zweiten Etage,
dann habe ich meine Wohnung und wenn ich Treppen steigen muss, dann muss ich auch eine Pause machen.
Nach dem ersten Stockwerk muss ich eine Pause machen.
Da muss ich mindestens ein, zwei Minuten pausieren und erst dann kann ich wieder weitergehen.
Aber ich habe eben auch die Luftnot im Liegen, im Bett.
Ich kann nicht flach liegen, besonders nicht gut auf der rechten Seite.
Sie haben auch Schlafprobleme, deswegen, oder?
Ja, auch.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Einschlafen oder durchschlafen?
Auch, das ist unterschiedlich. Mal kann ich schlecht einschlafen, mal kann ich schlecht durchschlafen.
Das wechselt.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Ausland gereist?
Im Ausland? Nein, im Ausland war ich nicht in letzter Zeit.
Nee, das letzte Mal, glaube ich, vor zwei Jahren war ich mal in Österreich, aber das ist schon zwei Jahre her.
Ja, okay, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie nachschweiß oder ausbürocken?
Ja, in letzter Zeit schwitze ich nachts auch stärker.
Ich denke immer, das hängt mit der Wärme zusammen.
Aber ich glaube, es hängt mit meiner Müdigkeit zusammen.
Ich verstehe.
Sie haben keine Brust und Bauchschmerzen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Und Herr Lohmann, ist Ihnen noch etwas aufgefallen?
Noch etwas, ja, in der letzter Zeit, ist Ihnen noch etwas aufgefallen?
Also mir ist aufgefallen, dass ich Gewicht verloren habe.
Gewicht verloren? Wie viel Kilo haben Sie?
7 Kilo innerhalb von 40, 4 Monaten.
4 Monaten.
Haben Sie Appetitlosigkeit?
Ja, auch.
Wie gesagt, mir ist in letzter Zeit müde.
Ich bin schlapp, ich bin nicht mehr so leistungsfähig.
Ich habe auch nicht mehr so guten Appetit.
Ja.
Okay.
Ich verstehe. Sind Sie vollständig?
Ja, ich dachte, gegen Corona.
Da achtet mein Hausarzt darauf, dass ich alle notwendigen Impfungen habe.
Kontrolliert der Hausarzt?
Ja, ja.
Und haben Sie Allergien?
Nein, Allergien sind bei mir nicht bekannt.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Unverdrecklichkeit gegen etwas zum Beispiel?
Nein, ist mir nicht bekannt.
Rauchen Sie?
Ich habe bis vor einem Jahr geraucht.
Da habe ich 40 Jahre lang geraucht, jeden Tag eine Schachtel.
Aber seit einem Jahr, seitdem ich diese chronische Bronchitis habe,
das habe ich jetzt schon, glaube ich, vier Jahre, fünf Jahre,
ist das bekannt.
Letztes Jahr ging es mir mal so schlecht, auch mit dem Husten.
Und da habe ich es geschafft, aufzuführen mit dem Rauchen.
Okay, das ist eine sehr gute Entscheidung.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Wir trinken abends so ein bis zwei kleine Flaschen Bier.
Kleine Flaschen, da ist so 0,3 drin.
Ich verstehe.
Ja, ich habe die Vorstände, die kranken Geschichten,
muss ich Ihnen nach Drogen fragen.
Bitte nehmen Sie nicht persönlich.
Nein, ich nehme keine Drogen.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben ein chronische Bronchitis.
Und wann haben Sie diese Diagnose bekommen?
Vor fünf Jahren.
Nehmen Sie dagegen irgendwelche Medikamente ein?
Nein.
Nur so manchmal im Winter, dann habe ich teilweise schwere Bronchitis,
auch mit Fieber.
Und dann muss ich in der Regel auch für einige Tage ein Antibiotikum nehmen.
Manchmal, ja.
Aber jetzt...
Zurzeit nicht.
Ja, haben Sie irgendwelche andere Vorerkrankungen
oder chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe hohe Hansare.
Ich hatte auch schon zweimal Gichtanfälle im linken Fuß.
Das war sehr schmerzhaft.
Und dann habe ich...
Vor drei Jahren wurde bei mir die rechte Niere entfernt,
weil ich Nierenkrebs hatte.
Da waren bisher die Kontrollen immer in Ordnung gewesen.
Ich gehe regelmäßig alle halbe Jahre zur Kontrolle.
Und das war bisher alles gut.
Vor drei Jahren.
Haben Sie Diabetes oder Hypert?
Nein, nein, habe ich nicht.
Mir ist jetzt eingefallen, ich nehme ja auch Medikamente ein
wegen der Gicht und wegen der Hansare.
Da nehme ich ja Tabletten ein.
Und ich nehme auch manchmal gegen die Bronchitis.
Ich nehme auch so ein Pulver ein.
Das tue ich in eine Kapsel, in ein Apparat, drückt drauf.
Und dann gibt es einen Staub, den muss ich einatmen.
Wie heißt das?
Das heißt Atmadesk.
Atmadesk.
Zweimal pro Tag.
Und das andere Mittel, wollen Sie das auch wissen, für die Hansare?
Wie heißt die Medikamente gegen Hansare?
Allopyrinol, oder?
Das Mittel heißt Allopyrinol 300.
Da nehme ich eine Tablette morgens.
Ich verstehe.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Ihre Rechte in Ihre Entfernung wurde.
Ja.
Vor drei Jahren.
Wurden Sie noch etwas operiert?
Ich hatte einen Alter von 10 Jahren.
Als Kind hatte ich einen Leistenbruch auf der rechten Seite.
Da wurde ich dann am Leistenbruch operiert.
Und dann hatte ich im Alter von 35 Jahren
eine Meniscus-Operation im linken Knie.
Da wurde eine Spiegelung gemacht.
Bei der Kniegelenkspiegelung wurde ein Teil des Meniscuses entfernt.
Alter von 35?
Da war ich 35 Jahre alt.
Das war jetzt fast vor 30 Jahren.
Hatten Sie in Operationen irgendwelche Komplikationen?
Nein.
Leben Ihre Eltern schon?
Noch.
Vater ist im Alter von 74 Jahren an Lungenkrebs gestorben.
Es tut mir leid.
74 Jahre.
Ja, im Alter von 74 Jahren.
Die Mutter lebt noch, die ist 87 Jahre.
Die Mutter hat hohe Blutdruck.
Sie hat erhöhte Knochenbrüchigkeit.
Sie hatte schon häufiger Knochenbrüche,
wenn sie so gefallen ist oder gestürzt ist.
Vor 3 Jahren hatte sie schwarzen Hautkrebs.
Schwarzen Hautkrebs?
Ja, das wurde operiert.
Das wird kontrolliert.
Und bisher waren die Ärzte zufrieden.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, meine Geschwister.
Sind Sie allein?
Nein, ich lebe mit meiner Frau.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, 2 Kinder, die sind 33 Jahre alt.
Die sind gesund, die wohnen aber nicht mehr bei uns.
Sind Sie Rentner?
Nein, ich bin im Straßenbau tätig.
Bis Ende des Jahres.
Dann werde ich pensioniert.
Straßenbau, was machen Sie?
Wir machen neue Straßen.
Wir tären die Straßen.
Wir haben neue Autobahnen.
Ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie mich fragen?
Was kann ich haben?
Das macht mir Sorgen.
Ich werde so schwach.
Ich werde mit dem Husten.
Ich kann nicht auf der Seite liegen.
Das habe ich so noch nie gehabt.
Das kann ich nicht ganz genau sagen.
Ich möchte erst mal Sie genau untersuchen.
Danach möchte ich einige Untersuchungen bei Ihnen.
Ich möchte Sie genau untersuchen.
Danach kann ich ganz genau sagen.
Das können wir so machen.
Prima.
Danke.
Dann haben Sie einige Minuten Zeit, sich vorzubereiten.
Die Patientensprache in Fachsprache zu übersetzen.
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Ich möchte Sie an die üblichen Geschichten.
Mit dem Husten, mit Auswurf.
Wenn Kollegen Fragen haben.
Wenn wir etwas noch nicht so richtig beantwortet haben.
Es gibt so ein oder zwei Sachen, die ich noch fragen würde.
Aber vielleicht sollten die Kolleginnen und Kollegen
erst mal schauen, ob es noch Ergänzungen gibt.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Wann sind Sie letztes Mal zum Arzt
eine Flogge
um die Karten...
Ich gehe da zur Zeit.
Ich gehe zur Zeit.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ich gehe da zur Zeit.
Ich gehe zur Zeit alle sechs Monate dahin.
Die letzte war das vor drei Monaten.
Da haben die Ärzte gesagt, es ist kein Grund zur Sorge.
Es ist in Ordnung.
Haben Sie Wasserlesenprobleme
oder
Blut im Urin?
Ja, die Frage wurde bisher nicht gestellt.
Wie ist das wichtig?
Also Wasser lassen, ich muss ein bis zweimal in der Nacht auf Toilette Wasser lassen.
Aber das macht mir sonst keine Beschwerden.
Blut im Urin ist bisher in letzter Zeit nicht festgestellt worden.
3-mal pro Nacht, letzter Zeit oder immer?
Ein bis zweimal pro Nacht, schon seit einigen Jahren.
Die Frage nach Stuhlgang sollte man natürlich dezediert fragen.
Der Stuhlgang ist eigentlich regelmäßig, ein bis zweimal pro Tag.
Da habe ich eigentlich nie große Probleme bisher mit gehabt.
Hatten Sie Luftschmutzung während Arbeit?
Luftverschmutzung.
Die Arbeit ist, manchmal ist die Luft nicht gut beim Straßenbau.
Es sind auch Teerdämpfe.
Manchmal haben wir diese Teerdämpfe, die sollen ja auch nicht so gesund sein.
Beim Asphaltieren einer Straße mit dem Teer.
Aber mein Arzt hat mir gesagt, ich bekomme eine stärkere Luftverschmutzung,
durch meinen Rauchen.
Das habe ich natürlich lange gemacht, 40 Jahre lang.
Würden Sie Lungen-Graphie durchgeführt?
Ich war seinerzeit, als diese chronische Bronchitis diagnostiziert wurde,
war ich beim Lungenfacharzt.
Das ist allerdings schon einige Jahre her.
Da stand dann jetzt in letzter Zeit doch das mit dem Nierenkrebs im Vordergrund.
Aber bei dieser Untersuchung Nierenkrebs wurde ich auch ganz gründlich untersucht
an den Lungen und an den Bronchen.
Aber das ist jetzt aber auch schon 2 Jahre, 2,5 Jahre her.
Dankeschön.
Ich kann versuhen.
Ja, bitte, versuchen Sie es.
Guten Tag, mein Name ist Grün-Görmez.
Ich bin heute bei Ihnen als Asthanarzt tätig.
Ich möchte Ihnen eine neue Patente vorstellen,
die ich eben in der Notaufnahme gesehen habe.
Herr Manfred Lohmann ist 63 Jahre Patientin.
Das Geburtsdatum ist 24.03.1962.
Der Patient kommt seit ungefähr einigen Wochen bestehende
und progrädierende Astheni-Displosion.
Der Patient hat auch seit einigen Wochen Auswurf bestreitet,
die Auswurf als gerätlich und rotlich und mit Fäden.
Die Fragen nach vieler Beide wurde vermeint.
Der Patient leidet unter auch seit einigen Wochen Ortopne.
Er kann nicht flach liegen.
Die Beschwerden verschlechtern sich beim Liegen im rechten Seite.
Auf der rechten Seite?
Ja, beim Treppen hochsteigen verschlechtern sich die Beschwerden auch.
Sie können sagen, es besteht eine Belastungsdisplö.
Ja, zum Beispiel beim Treppensteigen.
Der Patient hat seit einigen Wochen Belastungsdisplö.
Er berichtet davon, dass er beim Treppensteigen Pause machen musste.
Er hat Nachschweiß und der Patientin hat 7 kg in 4 Monaten abgenommen.
Das würde ich betonen.
Auffällig ist eine Gewichtsabnahme von 7 kg innerhalb von 4 Monaten.
Das ist eine wichtige Red Flag.
Das muss man schon etwas rausstellen.
Ich versuche mal zu wiederholen, was ich von Ihnen gehört habe.
Der Herr Lohmann ist ein 63-jähriger Patient.
Er ist seit einigen Wochen über Leistungsminderung, Fatigue, Dispne, produktiven Husten.
Er ist schleimig, geblich, bräunlich und mit teilweise rötlich.
Er besteht eine nächtliche Dispne, wenn er auf der rechten Seite liegt.
Er kann links besser liegen als rechts, aber rechts geht es nicht gut.
Der Patient hat keine Schmerzen.
Er besteht eine auffällige Gewichtsabnahme von 7 kg innerhalb von 4 Monaten.
Er besteht seit einigen Wochen eine Belastungsdisple.
Der Patient wohnt im zweiten Stockwerk.
Er muss nach dem ersten Stockwerk eine Pause machen.
Hat der Patient berichtet über UDEME?
Nein, die Frage nach UDEME wurde verneint.
Er leidet unter Schlagprobleme in der Zeit einigen Wochen.
Und Appetitlosigkeit.
Gut.
Der Patient hat seit 5 Jahren chronische Branche.
Er hat eine Erleichterung, die er nicht mit Medikamenten einnehmen.
Aber er nimmt meistens im Winter Antibiotikum ein.
Er nimmt oft Atmatiske.
Hat der Patient sonst noch chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, der Patient leidet unter Wut.
Er leidet unter Wut.